in this course I'll teach you how to use
Vector search and embeddings to easily
combine your data with large language
models like GPT 4 first I'll teach you
about the concepts and then I'll guide
you through developing three projects in
the first project we'll build a semantic
search feature to find movies using
natural language queries for this we'll
use Python machine learning models and
at list Vector search next we'll create
a simple question answering app that
uses the rag architecture and Alis
Vector search to answer questions using
your own data and in the final project
will modify a chat GPT clone so it
answers questions about contributing to
the freeco camp.org curriculum based on
the official
documentation and if you like you can
use your own data or documentation the
first two examples use Python and the
third uses JavaScript but you should be
able to follow along with just a basic
knowledge of either mongodb provided a
grant that made this course possible
their Atlas Vector search allows you to
perform semantic similarity searches on
your data which can be integrated with
llns to build AI powered
applications so let's start by talking
about Vector embeddings imagine you have
a lot of different objects like fruits
and you want to organize them in a way
that shows how similar or different they
are are in the real world you might sort
them by color size or taste in the
digital world we can do something
similar with data and that's where
Vector embeddings come in Vector
embeddings are like a digital way of
sorting or describing things each item
like a word image or anything else you
can think of is turned into a list of
numbers this list is called a vector the
cool part is that similar items will
have similar vectors by turning items
into vectors or lists of numbers we can
use math to understand and process them
for example we can measure how close two
vectors are to see how similar the items
they represent are words can be turned
into vectors and words with similar
meanings have vectors that are close
together this helps in tasks like
searching for information translating
languages or even shatting with AI
creating these embeddings usually
involves a lot of data and some complex
math the computer looks at many examples
like how words are used in sentences and
learns the best way to turn them into
vectors Vector search is a method used
to find and retrieve information that is
most similar or relevant to a given
query but instead of looking for exact
matches like traditional search engines
Vector search tries to understand the
meaning or context of the query Vector
search is a way to to implement semantic
search which means using the meaning of
words to find relevant results Vector
search uses vector embeddings by
transforming both the search query and
the items of the database like documents
images or products into vectors and then
comparing these vectors to find the best
matches in essence Vector search
leverages Vector embeddings to
understand the content and context of
both the query and the database item
by comparing these vectors it
efficiently finds and ranks the most
relevant results providing a powerful
tool for searching through large and
complex data sets MB Atlas Vector search
allows you to perform semantic
similarity searches on your data which
can be integrated with LMS to build AI
powered applications data from various
sources and in different formats can be
represented numerically as Vector
embeddings Atlas Vector search allows
you to to store Vector embeddings
alongside your Source data and metadata
leveraging the power of the document
model these Vector embeddings can then
be queried using an aggregation pipeline
to perform fast semantic similarity
search on the data using an approximate
nearest neighbors algorithm in this
course I'll be demonstrating how to use
Atlas Vector search in your applications
Atlas has a basic free tier m0 cluster
that you can use that is free
forever in this first project we'll
Implement semantic search for movie
recommendations we'll be using a sample
movie data set containing over 20,000
documents in mongodb and will'll be
using the All mini LM L6 V2 model from
hugging face for generating the vector
embedding during the index time as well
as query time but you can apply the same
concepts by using a data set and model
of your choice and our code we'll find
movies with semantic search using the
process I described earlier about Vector
search all the data including our
embeddings will be stored in a mongodb
instance so we'll be connecting our
mongodb instance but first we have to
create that and before we can create
that we need an account so let's create
a mongodb atlas account if you don't
already have one if you have one you can
just click sign in so you're basically
going to be clicking trree or sign in I
already have one so I'm just going to
click sign in and if if you're making
account for the first time it will
probably help you have you create a
project but uh since I already have an
account I'm going to go to new project
and then I'm just going to call this
gen
Ai and then
next and create
project okay now I need to create a
deployment and when we create an
deployment I if you are just creating
your account for the first time you'll
see this but I'm just going to create
the select the free options so we're
going to it doesn't matter really which
one of these you choose you don't even
have to have an account it's going to
set that all up for you so I'm just
going to set pretty much everything to
default and then I'll just click
create so you can see it's provisioning
right down here in the corner so here we
can set up the
authentication and I'm just going to
create this user it automatically gives
us a username and password we are going
to be working on our local
environment and since we're using the
local environment it already has
autofilled my IP address so I can click
finish and
close okay we are going to be using some
sample data pertaining to movies now you
could use your own data for this project
but mongodb offers some sample data so
I'm going to click load sample data and
you can see it say we are loading your
new data set to Cluster zero and this is
going to load quite a few different
sample data databases basically and we
are just going to be using the one
related to movies which is called sample
inflix we will look through the sample
data in a minute but it's still loading
so let's go over to visual studio code
or you can also do this on Jupiter
notebook or any other IDE but I'm going
to be using visual studio code you can
see I already have a file created movie
rex. py and first we need to install the
P package so I'm going to go to
the terminal and do pip or pip 3 install
P
okay now we see the sample data
set is deployed so I'll go to browse
collections you you can see we have all
these different collections here we're
just going to be using the sample inflix
collection and it has a bunch of movies
if I go to uh movies here you can see
here's the first one The Great Train
Robbery and then it has a plot it has
the
runtime the directors the the rating and
there a bunch of stuff about the movie
uh 1903 and there's a bunch of these you
can see if we look up here there is over
21,000 movies in this database so really
old ones to to newer movies so let's get
connected to this database from our
local environment so I'm in this file
I'm going to paste in some code we're
going to import P and then we are
going to connect to our database it says
your mongodb U well I'm going to have to
go and get that right now
so to get that we're going to go over to
here I'm going to click I'm go back to
this gen here's the cluster Zer
deployment I'm going go to view
deployment and then I can go to connect
over here and there's a few different
ways you can connect your database I'm
going to go to just the first one
drivers and uh you can go through and
select all these like um it's kind of
optional to to do that because we are
installed Pongo we really just need this
connection string right here so I'm
going to get the connection string and
then I am going to uh go over here and
for this example I'm going to hardcode
it into here but it's not best practice
you really want to use an environmental
environment variable but since I'm just
going to be running this locally it's
not going on to production or anything
I'm not putting on the GitHub I can I'm
just going to put this right into this
file here and then for the password now
I'm just going to show it to you um you
may have already seen it earlier I'm
going to delete this before I post this
video so I just have to go get my
password now when I was setting
everything up I could have used a
password I remember or copy my password
but I forgot to do that but that's no
problem we can just go to the security
database access and then here's the
account going to
edit and then edit password and then
we're just going to create a new
password it's just a bunch of random
letters I'll copy this and then I will
update user now I can go over here and I
can put in the
password now let's just do a quick test
to see if this is working I'm going to
do
print col collection
find.
liit five so we'll find the first five
items okay I'm going to save that and
we're going to try it on the
terminal okay we got the cursor object
that should be what we want now let's
try that one more
time okay good yes that's we went and we
got all that the first five items in the
database so we successfully connected to
our database the next step is that we're
going to set up the embedding creation
function there are many options for
creating embeddings like calling a
managed API or hosting your own model or
having a model run locally you can
create embeddings using the open AI API
that costs some money but there is a
free way to do it we're going to be
using the hugging face inference API and
we're going to use this model all- mini
lm- lx-
V2 hugging face is an open source
platform that provides tools for
building training and deploying machine
learning models and they make it easy to
use machine learning models via apis and
sdks so once we're on hugging face
you're going to make sure you create an
account or log in I already am logged in
to my account here and then we are going
to go to
settings access
tokens and then we are going to create a
new token and I'll just call
this gen
Ai and you want to make sure it's set to
read and then we can get the token to
authenticate to the hugging face
inference API so do is generate
token and now we're going to define a
function that will be able to generate
embeddings now this we're just going to
set this up and we're going to run in a
minute so I'm going to just get rid of
this and paste this we're going
to move input request to the
top and here we are going to have to put
in our
token now again you don't want to put it
in your file if you're going to be
putting this into production or or if
you're going to be putting this on
GitHub you want to use an e environment
variable but to make it simple and since
this is only local I'm going to put in
here and I am going to delete this token
before I publish the video so don't
worry about it being revealed or
anything so here's my token and then we
have this embedding
URL and we're going to generate the
embedding so you can see the function is
going to take in one argument to text
and it's expected to be a
string and this indicates that it's
going to return a list of
floats this is a typin suggesting that
the output will be a list where each
element is a floating Point number and
then we are going to make the request
request. poost to the embedding URL and
we have to pass in the token and then we
have to pass in the
text and then it's just going to return
the embeddings which is just going to be
a list of floats so we're just going to
add this final line to test this
generate embedding of free C Camp is
awesome so let's try this out we'll just
run
it it says the model is currently
loading so let's just try that
again
okay we didn't get the air but we forgot
to print it so let's print
that okay so that first thing I guess
the was just temporarily unavailable the
error but here is the embedding so you
can see this is just a list of floating
Point numbers which is the embedding
Vector generated for free C Camp is
awesome and it was derived using
the hugging face uh Transformer model
now the API we're using the hugging face
inference API is free to begin with and
it's meant for quick prototyping with
strict rate limits it is possible to set
up a paid plan a paid hugging face
inference inpoint and this will create a
private deployment of the model for you
just in case you're running into rate
limits but but we shouldn't need need
that right
now okay the next step is that we want
to create and store some em embeddings
based on our database so we're going to
execute an operation to create a vector
embedding for the data in the the plot
field in our movie documents and store
it in the database so the plot field is
just the plot of the movies in the
database um for instance the the sap
head this simple-minded son of a Min a
rich financier must find his own way in
the in the world you can see the popup
will tell you the the rest of the plot
so there's a simple There's a summary of
the plot of each movie in the database
and we are going to create an embedding
based on the plot field that will allow
us to search and find movies that have
some similarities in their plots and
will be able to use natural language to
do that creating Vector embeddings using
a machine learning model is necessary
for performing a similarity search based
on intent so let's update our code again
uh I added a new section to the
code and this is going to create Vector
embeddings for 50 documents in our data
set that have the field plot so for dock
in the collection find where there's a
plot that exists and just get
50 and then we are going to generate the
embedding based on the plot and you see
we're basically adding a new field right
to the database called plot embedding HF
and then the
replacing uh the collection. replace one
is going to update
the document in the database the the
movie information for that movie with
the new information which is basically
all the same except it has this new
field here now in this code we are
storing the vector embedding in the
original collection meaning alongside
the application data this could also be
done in a separate collection instead of
just replacing the document in the same
collection with the new one that has the
embedding we could create a separate
collection for the embeddings as we have
the original information it just depends
on your use case and how you want to do
that so I'm going to run this
code and we're not printing anything so
we shouldn't see anything in the
terminal but there will be a way to find
out if it worked successfully let's just
wait till it ends okay so it finished
running now I can go back to the
database and I'm going to just refresh
that so there's a refresh button right
here and if I scroll
down let's see if we have the new
field okay so this now has the plot
embedding HF
field and you can see these are the
vector embeddings that we just created
with the hugging face API and there's
quite a few so there's 383 embeddings
for this one and we did it for the first
50 so this one will have them and then
we can just if we scroll down lot so
this is the first 1 through
20 okay now I'm at results 61 through 80
so if we look that we know we don't have
that field here because we've only done
it for the first 50 results now
ideally for this project you would do it
for every single movie in the database
but because of the rate limits and
because of the time it would take to run
through all what was it 20 thou over
20,000 records I'm just doing the the
first 50 but if you want you can take
off the limit 50 and then run it for
every
single document in the collection that's
going to give the the best results when
you do the search but if you're going to
do all the documents you may need to
create a paid inference endpoint that I
was talking about
earlier okay the next step is to create
a vector search index so I'm going to go
back over to Mong B and we want to go to
the search tab
here so now we're we're at Atlas search
and we we're going to create an index
so let's just click create search index
and then we will use the Json editor and
next so there's a few steps we have to
do on this section first we need to
select the database and the collection
on the left so the
infix database and then we need the
movies
collection okay now we're going to enter
the index name where just going to call
this plot
semantic
search and then I'm just going to put in
some Json here let's look at this
Dynamic equal
true this indicates that mang Tob should
automatically index all fields in the
documents added to this collection so if
you have a varing or unknown schema you
may want to set to false and then only
Fields explicitly defined and the
mappings will be index index and then
for the fields so this is the name of
the field in the mongodb documents that
we want to index so remember we already
looked at that and when we were looking
at the example in the database we saw
that there were
384 numbers in each of under each of the
field remember it started at zero so it
all it went Zer to 383 this specifies
the dimensionality of the vectors stored
in the field the dimensionality is
important for the indexing and search
algorithms to to function correctly and
then similarity dotproduct this defines
this setting defines the similarity
metric used when performing searches
against this Vector field the dotproduct
similarity means that the dot product
between vectors will be used to measure
how similar they are a higher dotproduct
indicates greater similarity this is a
common choice for normalized vectors and
then we have the type KN andn Vector
this indicates the field is a K near
nearest neighbor Vector type Ken Vector
Fields allow you to perform efficient
similarity searches to find documents
with vectors vectors similar to a query
Vector then we can just click
next and then create search
index and you can see the the search
index build is now in process so it
takes a little bit of time to process
it okay it's done the the index is built
we are going to test it but not with
this button I'm going to go back over to
our
code and then I'm going to add a new
code snippet that will
explain first of all I did comment all
of this we could have made two separate
python files one to generate the
embeddings and one to use the embeddings
but we already generated them we don't
need to generate them again so I
commented all this out and now basically
this is what we're going to be this is
the code to try out and and use the
embeddings so this code will perform a
vector search in the mongodb collection
using the vector search aggregation
pipeline stage this is used to find
documents in the
collections who where the plot
embeddings HF
field is semantically similar to the
provided query so we got the query
imaginary characters from outer space at
War which you can try changing it to
something else and this sets the the the
query that we're going to use here when
see where it says vector query generate
embedding query so oh we actually do
need this part of the code I forgot we
just didn't need
to generate all the embeddings again but
we are going to generate the the
embedding for the query string that's
important so we're going to generate the
the embedding basically the list of
numbers for what we're searching for and
uh kind of to backtrack when it says
collection.
agregate that executes an aggregation
Pipeline on the collection and the
aggregation pipeline is a power field is
a powerful feature in mongodb that
allows you to process data and return
computed results so like I said this is
going to this is a specific stage that
is going to perform a vector search and
we already talked about create getting
the embedding and the path or the the
field basically that we're
using and then the num candidat 100 this
is an optimization parameter that tells
mangu to be how many candidate matches
to consider internally before returning
the final results a higher number can
improve the accuracy of the results but
may increase the computation size and
then the limit four that's just going to
limit the number of results return to
the top four matches uh you may want
to return a lot more than four like 10
20 but we're just going to limit it to
four and the index plot semantic search
well this specifies the name of the
index used for the search which is the
one that we created so now we're going
and so then the final part of the code
is going to go through every item in the
result and give us the movies now we're
just about to do it but remember we only
actually ran it on 50 movies if we had
created embeddings for every instead of
limit 50 if we did it all did it all of
them the results would be a little
better but let's see what we get when we
run on 50
[Music]
movies well I guess the first thing is
to fix the code and then we run on fthy
movies those curly braces and brackets
okay so remember the the query was
imaginary characters from outer space at
War so we basically got four different
ones so this one you can see it's about
going to war so that's kind of similar
this one's about going to war all these
have to do with war
none of them seem to have to do with
outer space but that's probably just
because the first 50 movies didn't have
very many outer space ones pulo garal
already created embeddings for all
20,000 plus movie plots in the database
and ran the same search term and came up
with these movies so we only created 50
embeddings but if we had created
embeddings for all of them this these
are the results that we would get when
it's looking at all the movies in the
database with with the embeddings it
would come up with movies that more
closely matched the query about the
imaginary characters from outer space at
War so this project was with the free
hugging face API to get the embeddings
if you want to use the open AI API to
get the embeddings for the search term
it is a paay API but the sample database
makes that a lot easier so we actually
added the embeddings to this movies
database but you can see there's already
an embedded movies database where
they've already and this is just part of
the sample data that you get and there's
already a plot embedding for each for
each item for each document all 3,483
documents and it's created with the open
AI API and you when you're getting
embeddings you basically have to use the
same API so we can't use the hugging
face API to do a search based on these
embeddings that were created with the
open AI API but let me just show you
really quick how we could use the open
ai ai embedding API to query based on
these embeddings that are already in
here and then we won't just be doing a
query based on a few of the embeddings
that we created for for this database
but we would be quering against every
document in the whole database so first
we're going to have to create a search
index pretty much just like before so
create new index Json
editor so first we'll choose the
database embed movies then index name
same as before we'll call this plot
Mantic
search and then this will be a little
different so the number of Dimensions is
different the path instead of plot and
Bings _ HF for hugging face it's just
plot and Bings that's the field and for
S similarity this time we're going to
use ukian so I'll go to next and create
the search
index now I already went ahead and
updated the code we have movie Rex 2 to
just use the open AI API so we let me
just show you a few of the differences
we input open AI API we have this API
key again you never want to put it right
in in the file but this is just for
demonstration purposes and I will be
deleting this API key before this video
goes live and this is all the same but
now when we generate the API we we have
this generate embedding function uh but
now the in what's in the function is
different so this is basically all
that's different so now we're using open
ai. embeddings that create and we use
this embedding model and now we are
going to get the embedding so basically
we already had this function generate
embedding and now we just change what's
inside that function to use the open AI
API instead of the hugging face API and
then the only other thing we changed is
the path is now plot embedding instead
of plot embedding underscore hugging
face so let's try running the function
let's try running this
code okay remember the query is
imaginary character from outer space and
now these are actually related to outer
space extraterrestrials who dominate
Earth we have uh aliens and imaginary
characters and they're going they're at
War we have Bender game which is again
uh Planet Express so that's related to
um planets and at War Guardians of the
Galaxy which is now another uh some more
imaginary characters outer space at War
so now that we are looking through the
entire database we get results that more
closely match our query you can see
there's no way we could get results like
this with just normal word searching but
when we search using Vector embeddings
we can have more semantic search we can
use more natural language to figure out
the movies that we actually want or if
you're not using a movie database
whatever is in your database it's going
to give a lot more power to your
searching so we just demonstrated how to
use hugging face inference apis how to
generate embeddings how to use Atlas
Vector search and we learned how to
build a semantic Search application to
find movies whose plots most closely
match the intent behind the natural
language query rather than searching
based on the existing keywords in the
data set we also demonstrated how
efficient it is to bring the power of
machine learning models to your data
using the analyst developer data
platform in the next project we'll look
again at using Atlas Vector search as a
vector store and how to deal with some
limitations of large language models
we'll also learn about retrieval
augmented generation or rag I'll
demonstrate how to develop a real world
project that uses these Technologies and
Concepts along with the Lang chain
framework open AI models and gradio
let's discuss some of the limitations of
llms that will be able to overcome using
Vector search llms sometimes generate
factually inaccurate or ungrounded
information a phenomenon known as
hallucinations llms are trained on a
static data set that was current only up
to a certain point in time this means
they might not have the information
about events or developments that
occurred after the training data was
collected llms don't have access to a
user's local data or personal databases
they can only generate responses based
on the knowledge they were trained on
which can limit their ability to provide
personalized or context specific
responses llns have a maximum limit on
the number of tokens or pieces of text
they can process in a single interaction
the retrieval augmented generation or
rag architecture was developed to
address these issues rag uses Vector
search to retrieve relevant documents
based on the input query it then
provides these retrieved documents as
context to the LM to help generate a
more informed and accurate response that
is instead of generating responses
purely from patterns learned during
training rag uses those relevant retriev
documents to help generate a more
informed and accurate response this
helps address the limitations in llms
specifically Rags minimize
hallucinations by grounding the model's
responses and factual information by
retrieving information from upto-date
sources rag ensures that the model's
responses reflect the most current and
accurate information available while rag
does not directly give llms access to a
user's local data it does allow them to
utilize external databases or knowledge
bases which can be updated with user
specific information also while rag does
not increase an llms token limit it does
make the model's use of tokens more
efficient by retrieving only the most
relevant documents for Genera a response
this section of the tutorial will
demonstrate how the rag architecture can
be leveraged with Atlas Vector search to
build a question answering application
against your own data let me quickly
tell you about some of the other
technologies will use for this project
Lang chain is a framework designed to
simplify the creation of llm
applications it provides a standard
interface for chains lots of
Integrations with other tools and into
and chains for common applications this
allows AI developers to build llm
applications that leverage external
sources of data in Lang chain a chain
refers to a sequence of components that
are linked together to process language
tasks each component in the chain
performs a specific function like
understand a query or generating
response and passes its output to the
next component in the sequence this
modular approach of chaining different
components or modules simplify complex
application development debugging and
maintenance this is not a link chain
tutorial so I'll only be briefly
describing these sections of our code
gadio is an open source python Library
that's used to build a web interface for
machine learning and data science
applications we'll be using the open AI
API to access two different models the
first is open ai's embedding model which
we use to create embeddings the second
is a large language model which we'll
use to generate text now now let's go to
the code editor so now we're going to
see how all these Concepts work by
creating a question answering app that
can answer questions from our custom
data we're going to start by installing
a bunch of packages so um a lot of these
are ones that we have talked about
linkchain
Pongo open Ai gradio and you'll see how
all the we use all these as we develop
our app
application you are going to need an
open AI account and you're going to have
to have enough credits which basically
means you're probably going to have to
have a paid account so I'm going to go
over to API keys and then I'm going to
create a new key let's call it
answer and I will be revoking this key
before this tutorial goes out so don't
worry about it being on screen or
anything I'm going I already have three
files made and I'm going to create save
the open AI key in this file so open
[Music]
AI API
key and in this file we are also going
to save our
URI and the URI we're just going
to use the same mango URI that we used
before we
can go to
connect
and it's just going to be
this and we have to make sure to update
the
password and then I'll just save that
file we shouldn't need that one anymore
so now we're going to use these two
scripts uh load data. Pi is going to be
used to load the documents and ingest
the text and Vector embeddings in a
mongodb collection and then extract
information will generate the user
interface and will allow us to perform
question answering against our data our
data using Atlas Vector search and open
aai we're going to import the same
libraries into each
file so P this open AI
embeddings mongodb Atlas Vector search
directory loader open AI retrieval QA
gradio base and then import key pram
which is basically just this other file
now we are going
to get our sample documents in this
tutorial we'll be loading three text
files from a directory using the
directory loader that's this one these
files should be saved in a directory
named Sample files so I'm going to
create a new directory called sample
files and then inside this directory
we'll have three files we'll have log
example.txt
we'll have chat
conversation.
txt
and
aerodynamics
txt and I'm just going to paste in some
text into each of these files if you
look in the description you can get all
the code and text that we're using in
this tutorial so in the log example just
going to go bam so we have just a bunch
this log here and then for the chat
conversation we're going to put a
sample chat conversation
and we can kind of go through it see it
says Alfred hi can you explain to me how
compression works and Mong be Bruce sure
mongod B supports compression of data at
rest it uses either ZB or Snappy
compression algorithms at the collection
level and then it kind of just kind of
explains how that works and
then with the conversation continues
Alfred interesting that's helpful to
know can you also tell me how index
indexes are stored in Mong b Bruce Mong
B indexes are stored in B trees so so
basically it's giving information about
how mongodb works so the last thing
we're going to uh the last file is
aerodynamics so this is giving
information about aerodynamics boundary
layer control achieved using suction or
blowing methods can significantly reduce
the aerodynamic lag drag on aircraft
Wing surface the ya Angle an aircraft
indicative of its side by-side motion is
crucial and so on so this is all
information that we're going to be able
to access within our our
chatbot okay we don't need these files
anymore so we're going to do a little
bit more of code that we're going to use
in both the load data and extract
information files but then they're going
to start being different so this is how
we're going to access our database so
first we're going to load the Mong Tob
client from our URL our database
name is linkchain demo collection name
collection of text block loobs and then
we we're going to get access to the
collection so both both files we need to
be able to get access to the collection
now we're going to start focusing on the
load data file and the next thing we're
going to do is initialize the directory
loader so I'm going to put a little more
code here and you can see it's going to
load the files it's going to load the
sample files directory and we're going
to load this data
and next this line here we're going to
define the open AI embedding model we
want to use for the source data the
embedding model is different from the
language generation model so we're using
the open AI embeddings model before we
showed how to get embeddings with the
hugging face API model but you can also
get embeddings from the open AI model
okay this next line we're going to
initialize the vector
store we're going to vectorize the text
from the documents using the specified
embedding model and insert them into the
specified mongodb collection so that's
what this whole thing is doing we see
we're passing in the data the embeddings
model and then the collection we're
going to put them into and it's just
using this Mong Alis Vector search
which we are importing here so now that
we have this this code is actually done
now and let's run it to create all the
embeddings and put them into the mongodb
collection so we'll just do
python load
data okay it it should be finished but
let's check so we'll go over here we're
going to go to our
Collections and look we have our Lang
chain demo and then here's the
collection of text blobs we have the
embeddings based on the first document
the chat conversation. txt the beddings
based on the aerodynamics document and
the log examples document and then we
can see the array so here's actually the
the array of all the floating Point
numbers and you can see let's see how
many there are this
time
1,535 actually 36 because it starts at
zero so we've create we successfully
created our
embeddings next step create our atas
search index so I'm going to go to
search and we have this one from before
but I'm going to create a new search
index use the Json
editor and then we have to choose the
right collections
and now we're going to update the Json
this time we'll just use the default
index name and everything's pretty
similar except our field is called
embedding and the dimensions are
different from the one from the example
from before and now we're using the
similarity of cosine which we can see it
it tells what that means it measures the
similarity based on the angle between
vectors allowing for similarity
measurements not scaled by magnitude so
depending on what you're trying to do
you're going to use different similarity
and we use the same type of cane and
Vector okay I will create the search
index and the build is now in process
while that build is happening we are
going to now fill out the extract
information
script and so all this is going to be
basically the same we're going to
connect to the client the same
uh collection but now it's going to
start to get a little different here and
we are going to obviously being we're
going to extract information so first
let's get access to the embed we're
basically defining the open AI embedding
model we want to use so that's basically
just like before we also want to get
access to our Vector store and we're
going to pass in the collection and the
embeddings model so now we're getting
access to the vector store that's stored
on the atlas basically this is the Atlas
Vector store that's stored on
mongodb okay now here's our query data
function it's going to take a query as
its input basically the person the user
is going to send a query and the
function is designed to process the
query and retrieve relevant information
using some different tools so the first
step in the
function have this one here it it invol
this is going to convert the input query
into a vector using open AI
embeddings this process is crucial for
preparing the query for similarity
searches in a vector space it's going to
perform an atlas Vector search using
Lang Chain's Vector store so the
similarity search passing the query in
K1 means we're going to retrieve the
most similar document from B based
on the query Vector so then this line
here is going to extract the page
content from the top document in the
return list which is the most relevant
information in our original
query so next we are going to define a
llm or a large language model using open
AI
API and if not specified the default
model use it you the default model used
is the Open Eyes GPT 3.5
turbo here we see the temperature set to
zero which generally means the model's
response will be more deterministic and
less
creative then we do a retriever here
we're going to initialize a retriever
for the mongod Tob Vector store this
retriever is responsible for fetching
documents that are relevant to our query
then here we're going to this uh
retrieval
QA uh this chain is then executed with
original query this process involves the
llm generating responses based on the
documents retrieved and the nature of
the query you see we're going to load
the stuff documents chain stuff
documents chain takes a list of
documents inserts them all into a prompt
and passes that prompt to an
llm and then finally we're going to
execute the
chain and then the function is going to
return two outputs the as output which
is the content of the most similar
document from the atlas Vector search
and the retriever output which is the
output generated by the retrieval QA
chain using the rag
architecture so this stri script
basically showcases is the
integration of of an advanced Ai and
database technology to create a powerful
tool for information retrieval and
processing we combine the capabilities
of open ai's language models open
mongodb's Vector search and Lang chain
to efficiently process and answer
complex
queries and next we have this basically
we're just creating a web interface for
the app using gradio now I'm not going
to go into a lot of details about this
CU that's kind of not really what this
tutorial is about but you can see it's
it's pretty simple it's just using
gradio to create a simple web interface
there's going to be some a text box
where we enter your question there's
going to be a submit button but one
thing I want to point out is that
there's two outputs and outputs
correspond to these two outputs from the
function the first output is just
what it would normally output with only
using Atlas Vector
search the second output is gener
generated by chaining Atlas Vector
search to L change retrieval QA and the
open AI llm so we can kind of see what
it would what it look what the output is
like just with normal Atlas Vector
search and with all these other tools so
let's test it out so we'll do
python EXT ract
information. and we just have to go to
this
URL so I'm just going to enter a
question did any error current August
16th if yes what was the error caused
by the apple with just Atlas Vector
search it Returns the text field as is
so basically that's the entire error it
doesn't do anything with it but when we
chain the search to L chain retrieval QA
and open AI the open AI LM yes an aor
occurred on August 16th eror was caused
by resume of chain stream was not
possible the resume Point May no longer
be in the oplog it's much easier to read
that way okay let's try one more what
questions did Alfred ask what were
Bruce's answers please summarize in
bullet
points here we're basically the
entire conversation the entire field but
down here it's actually able to do it uh
Alfred ask what does compression work
how does compression work m b how are
indexes stored MB and so on and then we
get the answers Mong supports
compression of data at rest using either
ZB or Snappy compression algorithms at
the collection level so now it's using
so now it's actually giving the answer
something that's in a way that's easier
to understand we can also use this for
sentiment analysis so I'm going to say
what was the overall sentiment of
Alfred's chat with Bruce what was the
likely
cat again we're just getting the entire
chat right in here but down here
Alfred's chat with Bruce was likely very
positive the conversation was focused on
technical details and Bruce was able to
provide helpful explanations the likely
SE cat would be high we can also use
this to get precise answer retrieval
like there's a lot of information how
can we get like an exact answer so how
about what's
y okay we have something that has some
information but it gives us a gives us a
lot more information it basically gives
us the whole text but here we have yah
is Angle an Al crafts an aircraft side
to side motion and it's controlled
primarily by the rudder and you can kind
of see where it comes from the angle of
aircraft side to side motion uh control
primary by the rotor but then we don't
get we don't get all the other
information that we don't need okay well
so in this section of the tutorial we've
seen how to build a question answering
app to converse with your private data
using atas Vector search as a vector
sore while leveraging the retrieval
augmented generation architecture with
Lang chain and open AI Vector stores or
vector databases play a crucial role in
building llm applications and rag is a
significant advancement in the field of
AI particularly in natural language
processing by pairing these together
it's possible to build powerful AI
powered applications for various use
cases and this final project will modify
a chat gbt clone so it answers questions
about contributing to the FOC cap.org
curriculum based on the official
documentation you can use these Concepts
to create your own chatbot that connects
with your own data to answer questions
this project has some similarities to
the last one but takes things to another
level so let's look at a chat gptt type
application that gets information from
your own documentation we'll be using
the free code Camp
documentation so a lot of this code is
already developed and I'll be walking
you through it and we'll be adding some
things so if you're following along at
home start by cloning the Repository I
have a link in the description and then
doing mpm install and then you're going
to have to configure the application we
have this emv. example you're going to
have to create a new file that's just
aemv and then you're just going to fill
in your open AI key and your Mong Tob
Atlas URI we I already showed you how to
get that URI in the the previous part of
the tutorial you can even use the same
URI that we already used for the first
project for all these projects you can
use the same mongodb Atlas URI with the
password and the username right in there
after you do that we can test the
application let's just do mpm run
Dev so here's what the application is
going to look like right now it's
basically just like chat GPT and it does
not use our own documents so I can
say write me a
poem about being a web
developer and it's using the open AI API
to do this but it's not accessing any
custom
information so let's now see how we can
make it access it can draw data from the
free Camp
documentation so first of all I want to
show you the documentation I'm talking
about this is specifically the
documentation on how to contribute to
free code Camp to help out with free
code Camp so there's a lot of sections
there's the getting started how to help
with translation and then the biggest
section is how to contribute to free Cod
Camp free C Camp freecodecamp.org is an
an open source project and you can help
out with the codebase so it talks about
how to set up locally the best practices
how to work on the codebase and so on
there's a lot of documentation on how to
get it set up locally the freec camp.org
and how to work on it and then there's
also some additional guides down here
and what we are going to do is we are
going to put all of this documentation
into our chat app so if you clone the
repo it will be all the documentation
will be right in assets FCC do FCC docs
and then we have the markdown file of
all the markdown files of all the
documents mentation on that page here
and so we are going to basically put all
this documentation into our chat app
we're going to do that by creating
embeddings for all this information and
then creating a vector search index it's
going to be kind of similar to what we
did in our first project but now we're
doing it with more data and more of a
real world type project so there's
already some code here to create the
embeddings so if we go
to create embeddings at MJS let's look
at this code
here so some of this is going to look
similar to code that we've already seen
so first off we're importing the
necessary modules so FS for the file
system operations then we have the
recursive character text splitter for
splitting text into chunks then this one
mongodb Atlas Vector search is for
storing vectors in mongodb Atlas and the
open AI embeddings from Lang chain is
for creating the embeddings and the
client for connecting to the
uh database and then EMV for the
environment variables and here kind of
like what you've already seen we're just
creating a m Tob client using the
connecting URI from the environment
variable and the script connects to the
docs database and the embeddings
collection next we specify the directory
containing our documents and read the
file name using the fsp do reader
directory so these are all our markdown
files from the free C Camp
documentation and then we're going to
start processing each document we're
going to read the content and log the
file name and then the next steps will
involve vectorizing the document so this
section right here we're going to create
a recursive character text splitter
configured for markdown langu language
and we're going to split the document
into CH chunks of 500 characters with a
50 character overlap and then we are
going to create the embeddings we're
going to use Mong be Alis Vector
search to create the embeddings for each
chunk using the open open AI embeddings
class and we're going to store them in
the mongodb atlas collection
and then finally we are going to close
the connection so basically the script
efficiently processes documents creating
embeddings and stores them in the mongod
to be Alis using the linkchain
library so now we're just going to run
this I'll run in the terminal down here
and just so you know how I'm going to do
it if I go into the package.json we have
an embed script that's just going to
call that file so I'll just do mpm run
embed and we can see it's going to
create embedding from all these
documents and it's vectorizing all of
them okay we're done now let's view the
embeddings in the database so I'm back
at mongod be
atas and I am going to go to browse
Collections and then here is the new one
docs embedding
these are the embeddings we just added
so if we scroll down we can see that we
have the embeddings for each document so
if we look at this one we can see the
embeddings
array 1,535 or
1,536 uh entries in the array or
documents so now we've created the
embeddings for everything you can see
some of the text right in
here and it's
bro broken that text into different
segments and create an embedding for
each one so at this point we need to
create the vector search
indexes this is very similar to what we
did before so I will scroll up to the
top of here not those if embeddings but
I'll go to
search and then I'm going to put create
search index then we'll go to the Json
editor
next and then we'll select the database
and connection so so embeddings and
we'll leave the default index
name and then we can see we're dealing
with the fields the field embeddings the
dimensions uh the similarity cosine this
measures the similar similarity based on
the angle between vectors allowing for
similarity measurements not scaled by
magnitude and then the type is K and and
vector and then next then create search
index okay now we just have to wait for
the build to to complete now we're going
to update the API routes to use these
embeddings so let's look at the current
API route again we're not building this
app from scratch the code is already
given so let's see what the API route
already looks like so this is the
default API route for chats and
basically just only uses the open AI API
without any of our extra information so
let's see what that looks like so we're
going to import the required modules and
we're using this streaming text response
for handling streaming text responses
obviously and then linkchain stream for
setting up a streaming Pipeline and then
message for representing the chat
messages and then we have chat open AI
which allows us to interact easily with
the open AI GPT model and then AI
message and human message from the Lang
chain schema for structuring messages
and we're going to set the runtime to
Edge this is indicating that the code is
designed to run on the edge potentially
in a browser or similar environment and
then we are going to handle post
requests we're going to extract the
messages payload from the incoming Json
request and then we're going to
initialize a Langan chain streaming
pipeline obtaining a stream and a set of
handlers to manage the flow of Text data
next we are going to create a an
instance of chat open AI specifying the
streaming mode to enable realtime
interactions with the open AI GPT
module and here we are using the the
call method on our chat open AI instance
to process each message messages are
mapped to either a human message or an
AI message based on the role the user or
the AI and the process me messages are
then sent through the Lang chain stream
using the provided handlers and then
finally we are going to return the
streaming response so now we're ready to
implement changes to our API route in
order to utilize Vector search with our
new embeddings so let's Implement a new
route dedicated to handling Vector
search so so we're going to start by
creating a new directory called Vector
search and then I will create a file
inside it called route.
TS and then I'll add some code so let's
talk about this code we import the
appropriate modules so this is for
creating embeddings and then this is for
Vector search obviously and this route
will connect to
mongodb but differently than we did
before because the mango client promise
you'll notice is from the app. li.
mongodb this is a promise that resolves
to a mongodb client we'll use this
promise to globally CL cache our mongodb
client so that we don't have to connect
to mongodb every time we want to make a
request this is a common pattern in
server serverless applications and it's
a good idea to do this in order to avoid
connection limits and you'll see that we
are receiving the user's prompt or
question from the request
body and then we'll use the mongodb
atlas Vector search Lang chain method to
create Vector embeddings for the user's
question remember we also have to create
Vector embeddings for the user
interaction so that we can then compare
it with the other Vector embeddings that
we have stored in DB for our customer
data then we tell it which collection
index name text key and embedding key to
use and then we do the
search we're using something called
maximum marginal relevance or MMR to
find the related
documents we can specify the the number
of results to fetch and how many of
those top results to return this allows
us to refine how accurate we want to be
and then finally we return our retriever
output now that we have a route
dedicated to Vector search we can update
our chat route to use it so we'll go
back to our chat route API chat route.
TS and here we're going to just
replace this section right here with a
whole new
section so we're using the same code
from before but now we're using the
vector search route to get the content
sections we'll then use the context
sections to create a template for the AI
to answer that
question so you can see we're
first getting we're extracting the
messages payload from the incoming Json
request and retrieving the content of
the current message for further
processing then we have a call to a well
a call to the vector search route using
the fets API and the current message
content is sent as the body of the
request and the response is awaited to
obtain the vector search results now we
have the template now this is all one
string and this is created for the AI to
respond so you can see it says you are a
very enthusiastic freeco camp.org
representative who loves to help people
given the following sections from the
freeco camp.org contributor
documentation answer the question using
only that information outputed in mark
marown format if you are unsure and the
answer is not explicitly written in the
documentation say sorry I don't know how
to help with that and then we are going
to get the context sections which is
basically what we got returned from the
vector search so this is basically what
we got from the vector search results so
we've already found the part of the
documentation that relates to what the
user just searched for and we have that
part of the documentation here and then
we have the question this is what the
question that the user asked so we're
going to now get the answer to the
question just using the context that we
got back from the vector search
request and then here we can see that
the content of the current message is
updated with the newly created template
and then a lang chain stream is
initialized to manage the flow of of
Text data now we have an instance of the
CH chat open Ai and it we specify the
GPT model and we enable the streaming
mode and this part is just like
before the message the messages
including the updated template are
processed by the GPT model using the
Lang chain call
method and then we just return the
streaming text response so let's test
this out mpm
runev so what do I need to know to start
contributing to
free code
Camp okay free cam runs on a modern
JavaScript stack if you're interested in
contributing to our code base you will
need something familiarity with
JavaScript and some of the Technologies
we use like nodejs mongodb a 2.0 react
gasp and web back well that was
helpful what is the process for creating
a poll
request okay and we
got the steps
for creating a poll
request so now I could keep asking more
questions based on the actual
documentation the actual freec camp.org
documentation we've reached the end of
the course you should now know enough to
implement Vector search in your own
projects thanks for watching